switzerland
is the most famously you might say
infamously neutral country in the world
that's why all the sketchy banking rules
are there and people put their money
there even in the hottest wars they
remain neutral that is how switzerland
has survived even switzerland
is throwing its neutrality to the wind
and coming out against russia
they're not admitting that they're doing
that but they are doing that they're
joining on to sanctions against
russia
switzerland don't we think of
switzerland as
maybe the most quintessentially european
country that there is
but switzerland is not in the european
union
switzerland is not in nato
switzerland is a neutral
country
and yet
they're signing on to these sanctions
against
russia and it it got me thinking here
what do we want we in the west
we we want everybody to be in the west
right that's what that's what
all of the wars of the 2000s were about
all of the bush wars
were okay these well one it was because
middle eastern terrorists launched a war
on us and then that war was used
right the attacks on september 11th were
used as
the justification for saying okay we
can't just let these people live and let
live do whatever they want because
they're going to come to our shores too
so we're going to remake the whole world
in the vein of madisonian democracy and
it's all we're all going to be the west
and we're all going to have iphones and
mcdonald's and we're all going to get
along just fine and it didn't really
work out
didn't work out very well in iraq didn't
work out in syria at all certainly
didn't work out in libya obviously
didn't work out in afghanistan where we
were just routed last year after 20
years mired in that backwater it didn't
totally work
even here this
vladimir putin who obviously wants to
expand his empire but he is using as the
pretext for this where he's saying the
problem is nato's expansion western
expansion in the early 1990s at the fall
of the soviet union nato said they
weren't going to expand east they did
expand east they expanded into former
warsaw pact former soviet nations we're
not going to allow that
ukraine is right up on our border and
you look at ukraine i suspect most
people can't find ukraine on a map it's
not your fault why would why would
people pay attention to the maps of
eastern europe i suspect joe biden can't
find ukraine on a map because he doesn't
know anything that is his fault he's the
president he should know where it is
but i bet hunter biden can find ukraine
on a map because he had a no-show job at
the at the corrupt oligarchic energy
industry in ukraine
adds even more complication to this
issue but ukraine
is right there between
europe
the eu
and russia
ukraine is a buffer state there's a
really good piece on this in tablet
magazine by lee smith
ukraine historically is a buffer state
and the thing about buffer states is
they've got to play nice with the big
powers on either side when buffer states
play nice with the big powers on either
side generally things are okay
but the minute that buffer states start
to turn to one side or the other
then you see tensions begin to rise and
what you saw in ukraine
for
the period before 2013 2014 is that
ukraine was tilting pro-russia
so then the west
through the encouragement of protests
through
direct funding of protests and activist
groups the west turned that government
ukraine a little more pro-western
actually a lot more pro-western actually
so pro-western that they wanted to join
nato and they wanted to join the
european union
all of a sudden russia says we can't
have this we cannot maybe we can
tolerate
nato expanding to
poland or hungary or may to some of
those eastern european states but we
can't tolerate them right up on our
border so all of a sudden when you when
even when you think you're going to
solve a problem by having ukraine join
nato what could be the downside of that
this is great all of a sudden now you've
you've gotten russia into the sort of
situation where they feel that it's in
their essential security interest to go
in and you have war this is something
that
very hawkish very serious very
well-respected foreign policy thinkers
in the 1990s warned nato about they said
do not expand nato eastward george
kennedy he's the author of the long
telegram he's the author of the strategy
of containment the
cold war strategy for containing
communist russia he said it's a huge
mistake it's a tragic mistake to expand
nato eastward you are going to squander
the victory of the cold war you're going
to create a new cold war that's what
we're seeing happen
right now i'm so glad you liked that
clip now you got to ring the bell ring
the bell subscribe get the notifications
especially this is what you really got
to do head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitch your google play wherever
you get your audio podcasts do it right
now i'll wait
you got it out good
type in the michael null show subscribe
leave a five star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you